The holidays in the States are a reason to
come together with family and pie and be thankful
for what you have, like pie, and take a break
and have some pie.
If you choose work over that something must
be wrong with your brain.
Hi knowledge junkies, Julian here for DNews.
Americans are a people who take pride in their
work ethic.
We’re a nation of builders, doers, dreamers,
makers, entrepreneurs, cliches!
But to quote the philosopher Strong Bad, too
much of a good thing is an awesome thing.
But too much of an awesome thing is really
really dumb and bad.
Workaholism is a loosely defined term right
now but the general consensus is it boils
down to being literally addicted to your work.
Although as a grammarholic I feel the need
to point out it should be an addiction to
workahol.
A recent meta analysis of the trait in the
Journal of Management shows that while some
may wear being a workaholic as a badge of
honor, it’s actually doing you more harm
than good.
Workaholics are more likely to skip meals,
are more stressed, have worse physical health,
and end up burned out on their job much sooner.
And you’re not even being more productive
to boot.
Dr. Brian E Robinson, author of Chained to
the Desk, says workaholics tend to get less
done because they take on too much work, don’t
delegate, and are often more disorganized
than their coworkers.
Melissa Clark, the lead author of the meta
analysis, does make a distinction between
workaholism and working more because you enjoy
your job.
People who work hard because they love what
they do don’t have any of the negative outcomes
their counterparts do.
And they can still step away from their work
without feeling guilt or shame.
Of course the benefit of working more hours
is more pay, so is that why people end up
skipping vacations and staying late?
Is it really an addiction to money?
According to the meta analysis, that’s not
it.
People who are workaholics tend to be perfectionists
or type A personalities; they do it because
they have an internal need they need to satisfy.
Just like how an addict has cravings.
So don’t overwork yourself; take a break,
step outside, have a cigarette.
I want to be completely clear, that was a
joke.
Do not smoke.
Does that really need to be said?
Anyway, this all comes back to the holiday
season.
Right now a lot of people have the choice
of working through the holidays or seeing
loved ones.
Remember, according to science, taking time
off will not only make you mentally and physically
healthier, but you’ll be a better worker
when you get back.
So relax.
See your family.
Have some pie.
If you’re like me and oh my god just love
pie, Tara and Anthony explain why it’s awesome
in all it’s forms here.
Can addictions be healthy?
I want to know your thoughts.
Tell us in the comments, and I’ll see you
next time on DNews.